right now a henderson mother is behind
bars accused of drowning and killing her
two young children
33 year old jovan trevino is taken into
custody in arizona we do thank you for
joining us
at six i'm brian loftus and i'm denise
valdez according to documents first
obtained by the i-team
she told police that she killed
one-year-old gianna fox
and four-year-old christopher fox the
third in separate
bathtubs she now faces two counts of
murder eight news now reporter sally
jaramillo from the neighborhood near
galleria and gibson
with what may have led up to her killing
her own children
sally denise and brian i spoke to the
father's side of the
family they tell me they would like some
privacy during this very difficult time
they did mention christopher was a sweet
charming little boy with a big heart
as for gianna she was sassy and loved to
dance
right now the community here and this
complex are still
hurting they're devastated as well and
are building a memorial currently
in this property in front of their home
according to the affidavit for warrant
from the henderson police department the
father of the children
is joven trevino's ex-fiance christopher
fox jr
he called police on monday reporting he
found both his kids dead in separate
bathtubs and trevino
missing foxx did have a temporary
protective order against him
and that he didn't kill his kids he went
to the home due to the fact that things
did not seem right
police did located the two bathtubs
filled with water also included in the
affidavit
a suicide note on the screen of
trevino's phone
saying quote she could not walk off this
earth and leave my precious children
behind
unquote detectives also found the knife
with blood on it
she did attempt suicide according to
police trevino says
she took a sleeping aid drank beer and
took a shot of tequila
before she drowned the kids trevino
checked herself into an e.r in bullhit
city arizona
admitting to staff that she just killed
her two children
now the father has set up a gofundme
page for his two children
and in a statement he says quote our
kids
had so much life ahead of them and we
wanted to see them prosper in whatever
they wanted to do in life
they would be truly missed as our hearts
are hurting right now
unquote that gofundme page can be found
on our website eight newsnow dot com
reporting live in henderson sally
jaramillo
8 news now